Bon, j'ai toujours pas de "+1" pour le mariage.
J'avais dis que je venais avec ma meuf.
T'as une meuf ?
Nan, mais je pensais peut-être la rencontrer d'ici là tu vois...
Attends, c'est le moment où il fait sa réplique là :
"C'est OK !"
Ah nan, c'est un peu plus tard...
Tu sais parfois, vaut mieux être seul que mal accompagné...
"Jour, nuit"
Ah, c'est du génie !
Bah, t'façon, j'ai le temps là... C'est quand le mariage ?
Demain.
[musique rock]
Être adulte, c'est aussi ne pas céder
à la pression du système, qui nous impose d'être en couple obligatoirement
alors qu'on peut très bien être célibataire et heureux, hein
Même si être en couple, c'est quand même cool... Enfin bref !
Noëlla ? ouais... Laure ? ouais...
Cerise ? Pas mal, Cerise...
Bénédicte ? Oh, allez hop !
Dorothée ? Dorothée, ouais
Nan mais mec, tu vas pas choisir des filles au hasard comme ça ?
Faut que tu trouves quelqu'un qui te corresponde vraiment !
Ouais, t'as raison. Là il me faut pas un +1, il faut vraiment que je trouve la femme de ma vie, là.
Ouais, ouais c'est vrai que
Tu vas réussir à faire en 24 heures ce que t'as jamais réussi à faire en 29 ans.
Et si j'activais l'option Premium, à 2€ ?
Ouais, commence par ça ouais...
Tu me prêtes ta carte ?
Skate, ouais, jeux de baston, ouais
Rap US, oui
Mangas, obligé
Hamburger, ouais
J'suis pas sûr que tu trouves une fille qui corresponde à tous ces critères...
"Lancer la recherche"
Oh ! Un profil trouvé !
Hein ? Monsieur "médisant" toujours...
Je peux voir le profil ?
C'est le mien.
Je correspond à mes critères.
(Natoo !)
(Viens !)
(Vas-y viens !)
(T'as toujours envie de larguer ton mec ?)
(Bah oui.)
(Bon j'ai une solution : tu le largues, on va ensemble au mariage, et comme ça tu deviens mon +1.)
(Mais euh... On n'aura pas à coucher ensemble ?)
(Non.)
(OK, ça me va.)
-- Eh !
-- Hum hum !
On se regarde le 2 ?
Ah ouais ouais carrément, ouais...
Avec joie...
(Vas-y, largue-le !)
Ouais, j'y vais là...
(Bah non, t'es encore là ! Vas-y, vas le larguer !)
Oui, j'y vais
(Tu prends ton corps, comme ça, et tu vas le larguer, comme cela, voilà !)
(Allez, largue-le !)
Bon j'y vais !
T'as un rendez-vous ?
Ouais j'ai un date avec une meuf du web, là
En gros c'est une meuf, j'ai vu son visage dans un reflet sur une photo, elle est très très belle.
Allez, ciao le geek !
C'est la bonne ! Sûr !
Bon, c'est une super machine mais il faut la laver régulièrement.
D'accord.
Donc vous avez différents modes...
Et sinon, petite question, c'est vrai que ça a aucun rapport mais euh... Qu'est-ce que vous faites dans la vie ?
-- Différents modes... -- Différents modes, ouais !
-- Le mode "cuisson rapide"...
-- "Cuisson rapide " ? ouais, donc : femme active, euh...
peut-être célibataire...
-- Le mode "gâteau" ...
...gâteau
-- et le mode "brioche"
Bah, "brioche", c'est..  ça, c'est tout ce que j'aime ça, tu sais... moi j'suis très brioche à la base.
Ah ! Bon, t'as maintenant un... hmmm...
mini-frigo ?
Alors, c'est pas un mini-frigo,
c'est une machine à pain.
Elle coûtait super cher et je l'ai eue à un très bon prix.
En plus, il y a un mode brioche qui est...
bon, ok, j'ai pas de meuf.
Vas-y, j'appelle mes ex.
Non, non, Norman, appelles pas tes ex, c'est une très mauvaise idée, tu sais.
Bon, j'appelle seulement celles avec qui il s'est jamais rien passé et c'est resté en suspens, ok ?
Presque toutes, alors.
... Ouais, presque toutes.
Allô, Coline ?
Ouais, c'est Norman, on était en quatrième ensemble
et fait un TPE sur... sur Adolf Hitler.
Ça va ?
... Allô ?
"Comment séduire une fille en moins d'une heure.
Première technique, elle est pas négligeable :
Lavez-vous.
Très important de se laver, certains mecs négligent cet aspect-là,
pourtant il faut se laver. Donc.."
"Pour apprendre à larguer son mec de façon très simple,
il y a plusieurs types de mythos, du genre :
*plop* ' tu es trop bien pour moi '
* plop * ' je suis désolée mais malheureusement j'ai l'impression que  je te tire vers le bas '
* plop * ' je me sens pas capable d'être avec toi '
* plop * ' je me sens vraiment trop nulle par rapport à toi
et je pense que tu trouveras mieux ailleurs '
" Ça, généralement, ça passe toujours plutôt bien."
-- pffff !
Plus vite, s'il te plaît ! * bip bip *
On va la perdre !
Je suis à fond là !
T'es sûr que tu vas trouver une fille ici ?
Bien sûr, c'est écrit là ! Regarde. * bip bip*
Allez, papou, vas-y !
Tu vas trouver une chèvre ici, maximum....
Et maintenant à gauche, à gauche !
C'est pas une route ça !
C'est pas grave, vas-y ! ... Voilà. * accélération des bips *
Yes ! Juste là. Nickel !
Ah bah voilà...
Il y a rien là !
Qu'est-ce qu'il fout ?
"Aucun profil aux alentours," putain !
Merde !
Chloé28 !
Chloé ?
Chloé28, on avait une affinité...
On aime bien le badminton.
Peut-être que t'es pas fait pour vivre avec quelqu'un, hein ?
Y a des gens, ils sont tout seuls toute leur vie, ça leur va très bien.
Super, ouais.
Tiens, Laurie m'a acheté une cravate pour demain.
Elle connaît tellement bien mes goûts.
C'est une femme parfaite, hein ?
Marie-toi avec, ta femme parfaite !
Attends, je l'appelle...
Ouais, chérie ? La cravate est super, ouais.
Tu sais, il faut pas forcer les choses.
Je suis sûr que le jour tu t'y attendras pas,
puis tu vas tomber sur la femme de ta vie, comme ça.
Ouais, bien sûr. Et je la trouve où cette femme ?
Oh, j'en sais rien moi.
Un anniversaire, un bal, une bar mitzvah, n'importe où...
Et à un mariage ? Ça marche ?
Ah oui, ça c'est connu. Dans les mariages, il y a plein de célibataires.
Moi, quand j'étais jeune,
pour pécho, j'allais dans les mariages, même pas invité...
...Ok, ok, c'est bon.
Allez, va... ca va le faire !
[musique rock]
...